Marvel's rebooting the Ultimate Universe
resetting whatever you want to call it
and is being done by Jonathan Hickman
y'all know how much I love Jonathan I'm
sorry I'm so excited people I'm gonna
get more excited as this story goes on
because what this does is this opens up
two months ago right with what basically
looks like a like a heist it's these
guys who are literally riding in this
unmarked van they go busting into this
building and it looks exactly like a
kind of heist I mean you got armed
soldiers and stuff in there these guys
roll in and just start shooting the
place up they take these guards out like
that now they're using like Hypersonic
weapons and all kinds of stuff super
high-tech stuff which is Way Beyond what
mercenaries would normally use so right
off the bat we know these guys are being
funded in some capacity by somebody else
right they take out the armed guards
they even go to this poor girl and they
tell her like are you the manager here
she's like I mean I don't I'm not really
a manager but you have a key and her
response is like yes these guys even
detonate a mini black hole they create a
singularity in this place it sucks
everything in and then disappears it's
crazy right it's it's nuts like within
an instant they're coming in guns
blazing right it's just it's crazy it's
absolutely nuts so what they end up
doing is as they make their way into
this facility one of the guys tells them
this is not a bank and they're like we
know and so once they get to the
location they're supposed to be at they
end up finding what looks like this
giant room right this giant like black
box with a door on it once they open it
we find out they're here to retrieve
somebody and the questions got to be
asked who in the world are they going
through all this trouble for to get
because one of the guys is like we're
being paid a lot of money right like
billions of dollars and they're like yes
right the leader of them is like yes
you're being paid all that money but
once they get in there this guy is just
like right on time and when he turns
around it's the maker son it's the maker
these guys were hired to break out the
maker and let me tell you something man
all right those guys who don't know the
maker in the Ultimate Universe of Marvel
Comics and you know what let's explain
the Ultimate Universe here for a second
here's a quick 15 second explanation of
the Ultimate Universe the Ultimate
Universe was launched in the year 2000
as an answer to the question what if
superheroes had emerged for the very
first time in the year 2000 that was it
it kicked off with Ultimate Spider-Man
and just went forward from there the
maker is the Ultimate Universe version
of Reed Richards who became a bad guy
and he is dope but he's basically like
Reed Richards from the main Marvel
Universe with zero restraint and nothing
but nefarious intentions this guy is
amazing I love his character so much and
so what he literally does here is he
kind of has a little bit of fun with
these guys right remember the maker is
incredibly intelligent he's the smartest
person in the Ultimate Universe Next
Level right this is a whole different
world when it comes to the Ultimate
Universe here and where the guys ask the
question they say where's our money his
response is ambiguous at best right
where all money is floating in The Ether
awaiting summons from an imaginary state
to a more believable fiction which is
usually true right money's not real at
least that's what some people say and so
one of these guys responds and says it
sounds like you don't really have the
money and his answer is oh I promise you
whatever it is I most certainly have it
now here's the thing you do not enter
into a bargain with the maker lightly
because nine times out of ten it's like
entering into a bargain with Mephisto
you could do it but you do it at your
own risk there's going to be some kind
of a catch some kind of caveat and I'm
gonna tell you guys right now what
happens to these dudes man it's gruesome
it's straight up gruesome but it's
nothing compared to what the Maker's
about to do here in a little while man
because
this man's got a bone to pick and
everybody's about to suffer right like
everybody's getting a piece of this pie
whether they want it or not so these
guys like once they really start
realizing there's no real money to be
had here but they asked the question
they say so so what you're telling me is
you hired us to break you out but the
this guy who's so capable and so
intelligent didn't have the didn't have
the ability to break himself out no no
there's got to be something bigger going
on here what they did is they had
actually retrieved an artifact and then
brought it to the maker as part of the
contract right the agreement that was
struck between all of them and so as he
starts talking to them he asks them like
about their individual names and their
identities kind of getting to know them
on a personal level one of the guys
who's here his name is Jackson he's not
supposed to be here instead it was
supposed to be a guy named Keith Conrad
but he basically got cold feed he backed
out and the rest of the crew killed
Keith for the fact that he defected but
Reed goes on to have this like amazing
statement right he says the unforeseen
complications of impatience and in UI
trapped here I'd forgotten what most
people call discipline I of course
planned for overlap but the genetic
sequencing was for u4 for a reason each
and every ingredient is what makes for
good soup this will present as a less
than one percent anomaly most people
would miss it but I wouldn't and he
certainly wouldn't which vexes me to no
end I suppose my choice now is a subtle
prayer or a more on brand message and
one of the guys responds and saying like
it was the last minute right like
literally this guy bailed out we did the
best we could with what we had we had to
grab this guy and the response here of
Reed is very very telling right like pay
attention to this he says your best
there was one of my therapists in here
who before I did what had to be done did
have a surprising effect on me he
encouraged and challenged me in a way I
did not believe was possible his ideas
of acceptable goals and personal
betterment were predictably
short-sighted but he actually did make
me want to be a better man a better man
with better goals now this is not some
altruistic thing this is not Reid
Richards understanding what's going on
it's like oh yeah I've I've turned over
a new leaf and I'm becoming a good guy
no he's still a villain he activates
this device and the genetic sequencer
merges all the mercenaries together
literally just like merges them they get
transmogrified into a version of read
and that's the one percent anomaly he
was talking about because the genetic
sequencing was based on each one of
these individual guys had Keith actually
shown up the way he was supposed to this
dude would look exactly like Reed down
to a t such as it is he's missing the
scar and he's partially drooling it's
not the way that Reed is supposed to be
but one of the things that he says here
as he walks away is I do have limits so
in effect evil Reed Richards is free in
the main Marvel Universe now one of the
things you guys are undoubtedly going to
be asking is yes raw but I thought
ultimate read return to the Ultimate
Universe because I thought it already
came back technically it did right like
he was supposedly contracted by the
Council of reads and all that kind of
stuff it looks like Jonathan hibbons
ignoring all of that stuff so we can
ignore it too right you can largely even
just treat this as though ultimate read
has just been here and you haven't seen
him one time since the events of the end
of secret Ward and in fact even the
statements that he makes run contrary to
everything that's happened so far with
his character and his appearance Post
Secret Wars post 2015. so following this
in the aftermath of this whole Black
Guard building explosion right like read
escaping that was two months ago right
six weeks ago you have main Marvel
Universe Reed Richards and you've got
black panther who are basically talking
to each other and one of the things to
know here and this is something that a
lot of people tend to forget they have a
very very close friendship they've been
friends for an incredibly long amount of
time it's the reason why in the
aftermath of Doom War when t'challa lost
the role of black panther after handing
it over to shuri that Reed accompanied
him down to meet bass the goddess right
and then in turn bass made to Chala the
king of the Dead Reed was the one that
had to vouch for him right that's how
deep the relationship goes they're more
like brothers as opposed to friends and
so as they start talking here and as
they they start communicating what they
end up finding out is that this facility
was a holding facility for damage
control right now here's the thing
damage control nine times out of ten in
Marvel Comics they're the cleanup crew
right you never really see damage
control on this side which is basically
putting people in these extremely secure
facilities and so once Reed realizes
that this place is a damage control
holding facility it suddenly Dawns on
him who it is is being held here he
figures out it's the maker now once they
get into that room the maker whose face
now looks the way that it's supposed to
and his body has presumably taken on at
least the form and the mannerisms that
it's supposed to as soon as Reed walks
in he asks the question maker is that
you right are you really me is it is it
you that I'm looking at here and the
body of course immediately dissolves and
so what the maker was doing here was
putting on a show this was not by
accident it's not sloppy and that's one
of the things that I want you to notice
here everything the maker does here is
done with intention there's no accidents
there's no coincidences nothing happens
because it sort of ended up that way
it's all according to design that's how
this guy works and so where black
panther asked the question where in the
world is this guy at right this evil
version of you who seemingly every bit
as intelligent as you the response of
read is I'm not worried about where he
is I'm worried about what he's doing and
so what we end up doing is we actually
jump to about five weeks ago when the
Maker shows up to the Baxter building
now remember the Baxter building's a
home with a Fantastic Four and it's got
all these security systems right retinal
scans and all that kind of stuff but
they're all predicated on the identity
of Reed the maker is Reid Richards from
an alternate reality the machine's not
going to be able to differentiate
between the two and so the maker can
just Waltz right in he walks right past
Franklin who has no powers right he's
not a reality warper anymore he ends up
going into the computer systems of Reed
and then he starts looking through
everything and so what Reed does right
after the maker has been through there
and Reed realizes that the maker had
arrived there Reed does the only thing
he can do he goes to the necropolis and
he recalls the Illuminati they're back
ladies and gentlemen the Illuminati are
back just now there's also big
differences here right like remember
when the Illuminati were first formed
this was the original team this is what
the team looked like right Captain
America was revealed to be part of the
Illuminati during the events of original
sin back in the day but he ended up
joining the team after Professor Xavier
was killed during the events of Avengers
vs X-Men so Captain America was never
originally part of the roster but the
gang's all here ladies and gentlemen
right you got Doctor Strange you got
Iron Man you got black panther you got
Professor Xavier you got name of the
Submariner you got black ball nobody
cares but you have like the the original
team back together and that's awesome
except for blackball because Black Bolt
sucks but the team basically starts
asking the question what's going on so
what they do is they put all their
resources together right now check this
out this is where things get nuts right
they say that the maker came to wakanda
and successfully really stole enough
vibranium to forge it into who knows
what that's no small thing but only Reed
Richards is allowed access on that level
because this is an alternate version of
read he's able to access that stuff you
see the benefit of being the maker in
the main Marvel Universe right everybody
trust Reed Richards in the main Marvel
Universe right he's part of the
Fantastic Four suddenly you have an evil
version of him nobody who ever really
sees that coming the next thing we learn
is that the maker went to a Talon which
is not surprising because the Inhumans
suck and he stole a whole bunch of
terrigen spheres that have enough energy
to power massive cities for over a
thousand years after that he went to the
bridge now as soon as I saw the bridge I
was like what no way because the bridge
is supposed to be gone right the bridge
is supposed to be destroyed for those of
you guys who don't know what the bridge
is in Marvel Comics it's one of the
coolest things so the Bridge originally
appeared in the dark rain line of comics
as part of Marvel's kind of branding
initiative during this point in time
Reed Richards constructed the bridge in
in order to look into the Multiverse and
that's when he first met the Council of
reads he was told by Susan storm to shut
the bridge off but he lied to her he
lied to his wife he actually ended up
reactivating it and then traveled
through and that basically gives us the
entirety of Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic
Four run going forward from that moment
now the bridge itself was destroyed at
the end of Hickman's run but it was
brought back during the events of the
collapse of the Multiverse right the
multiversal incursions do you guys
remember that story Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers the greatest
comic book story ever told by man it
took like five years for them to finish
it man it was like it was like the
greatest comic book run of all time but
the thing here is that the bridge is
supposed to have been gone right it's
not supposed to be there apparently Tony
Stark has it and he has it in some
secret Warehouse out there somewhere
right why does Tony Stark do that
because Tony Stark's a dick right the
other thing about this is that you end
up having the maker who basically
travels to the sanctum State term of
doctor strange and he steals and
Immunity Lance he goes to Atlantis and
he steals from Atlantis but he's
stealing all these different artifacts
all these different things and by
whatever Manner and whatever means which
they don't even understand how he was
able to do it he broke into krakowa
right the mutant Island that can only be
accessible by the mutant population they
don't even know how he did it but he
broke in there and he stole a krakowan
gate they're supposed to be immovable
right once icker Cohen gate is planted
it can't be removed it can't be taken
out by any feasible means outside of
like reality warping or something crazy
like that and so what ends up going on
here right after maker has stolen all
this stuff he goes to the one person
that you would expect him to visit now
we know this anybody who's been reading
Marvel Comics for a long time knows that
this was gonna happen it was gonna
happen these two were going to meet
right the maker goes and visits Miles
Morales son yes he goes and sees my
miles more hours why okay so here's the
thing man those see that so those of you
guys who are new to comic books this is
why this stuff is so amazing right so
the thing about this is that the maker
wakes them up right he wakes up miles
and he says how can you possibly sleep
with the world moving as it is the gears
of this fraudulent infernal machine
grinding our bones to dust and it takes
Miles by surprise right he's like who in
the world are you now this is one of
those instances what I'm talking about
where I say that like the makers met
miles before after the events of secret
wars during like absolute Carnage King
and black all that kind of stuff you can
ignore all of that right just act like
you've never seen the maker before but
his response is have we not met I cannot
tell with so many of you the masks and
monikers and more than that the
repetitive nature of so many of you
Heroes and where where Miles asked like
who are you this guy responds right the
make a response and says you are Miles
Morales and I am your brother and where
Miles doesn't know what he's talking
about he says I read about it in his
records it was some trick of universal
rebirth and reality shaping but as I
understand it according to the secret
history it's something every creature on
this planet in this universe shares but
you and I have something that sets us
apart from them apart from their shared
history we are the only two survivors of
a dead Universe miles the only living
children of gods erased from history did
you know that now here's what the
Maker's talking about because if you're
not familiar with comic books you're
probably like what in the world is going
on okay so in Marvel Comics and kind of
referencing back to our explanation of
the Ultimate Universe the Ultimate
Universe was really really popular but
when the Multiverse was basically
collapsing and all these different
universes were coming to an end the
final incursion meaning the final two
universes that collided was the main
Marvel Universe and the Ultimate
Universe now Miles Morales actually
ended up stowing away on what was
basically a safety vessel devised by the
good guy Reed Richards right so when you
got to the events of Secret Wars Miles
Morales remembered the entirety of the
Ultimate Universe the universe he came
from everything that had ever happened
the death of his mom Rio and the comics
the whole nine yards and so because of
that once Secret Wars ended Miles
Morales ended up in the main Marvel
Universe and so one of the gifts that he
was given by the molecule man Owen Reese
which believe it or not the reason why
this happened is because miles gave the
molecule man a cheeseburger you don't
have to believe me it's 100 true I'm not
even lying and that moment in the story
was amazing but the reward that was
given to Miles as a result of that is
that when he re-emerged in the main
Marvel Universe when Reed Richards said
everything back to normal Rio was
brought back to life so he finally got
his family back that's why if you read
miles or you're just now getting into
miles that you go from the Ultimate
Universe where his mom is dead when she
was killed at the hands of Venom to
suddenly she's alive and so what ends up
happening here is that as the two of
them are talking the maker literally
tells miles he says it would feel wrong
to go back and to basically recreate all
of reality without coming to you and
talking to you first and asking you do
you want to join me do you want to go
back home now the reality here is that
Miles has settled in in the main Marvel
Universe right this is his new home now
if he went back to the life that he had
before it would be the life where his
father his uncle Aaron who's dead his
mom who was killed by Venom there's
nothing for him back in the way that
things used to be and so the result of
this is he rejects the offer of the
maker and so the maker gives him an
empty card and says if you ever change
your mind you know how to get a hold of
me and he ultimately leaves and so
following this you basically switch over
to the here and now in this moment right
the Illuminati have banded together and
they're trying to basically stop the
maker who's on top of the Baxter
building with basically all these
artifacts that he's gathered for the
purpose of jumping back to his native
reality not only jumping back to his
reality but resetting everything
rebooting every thing now initially the
Illuminati do what they can where they
can but understand this is read right
whether it's the ultimate Universe
version bad version of read or the good
version of read he accounts for
everything and so what he does here is
he opens up a portal right to basically
jump through and to send himself back to
the Ultimate Universe and you literally
have like blackball who screams because
you know that's all they can do I just
scream like a little girl and then
you've got the other members of the
Illuminati who were all using their
powers it doesn't do anything right the
building gets leveled the whole nine
yards nothing happens Reed even looks at
them right like maker looks at him it's
just like you guys done you guys
finished because I mean I've got I got
places to be so if you guys are done
I'm gonna go ahead and Jet That's how
little he cares about the situation and
so one of the last things he does is he
asks main Marvel Universe read if you
could do it all over again if you could
go back to the moment when the molecule
man gave you that power to reset the
entirety of the Marvel Universe if you
had that moment to wipe me from
existence would you do it and the
response of read is yes I absolutely
would have and the maker says I'll keep
that in mind and so with him jumping
through the portal the superheroes the
Illuminati are helpless to stop him
there's nothing they can do and so what
this does here what this does ladies and
gentlemen what this does is this
switches over to a field trip
oh it switches over to a field trip
right like a science trip right you've
got Peter Parker and you've got Liz
it's the origin of Ultimate Spider-Man
right like it's the origin of Ultimate
Spider-Man they're there they're looking
around they're doing all the kind of
stuff that you would normally expect
Peter's taking a look at everything and
the radioactive spider makes its way
down and it lands on Peter Parker's hand
and the maker plucks it off he takes the
spider off of his hand he prevents Peter
Parker from becoming Spider-Man that's
that's literally he's just like
reworking and restructuring everything I
saw this and I was like there's no
Spider-Man in this universe like the
makers reworking and just restructuring
everything he's rebuilding it all it's
crazy with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end now you
know what this means right we gotta
cover the Ultimate Universe thank you
all for watching and I will catch you on
later peace